This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into things, this episode does deal with discussions of abuse, please just take a moment to assess whether that is something that you are ready to hear today. This episode will still be here tomorrow. It will still be here in a week, in a few months,
when you are in a better headspace to perhaps return to it. So it is your decision, but just giving you a heads up and a reminder to please take care of yourself. A really hot topic in the dating realm in the dating world at the moment is love bombing. And it has been for a while now. You see TikToks and reels of it everywhere, articles about how to tell if he's love bumming you. You hear horror stories from people who think that they have found the one and discover, you know, three months later that it was all a manipulation strategy,
these grand gestures that leave us confused as to whether this person is truly infatuated with us or just likes the idea of you or is just trying to get something from you. It can all be a little bit confusing to distinguish between a true connection and love bombing, especially in this day and age when there is so much confusion and contradictory information about what actually constitutes a love bombing situation and when to be worried. It's something we see a lot, right? You know, when a term like love bombing enters our collective psychobabble, it can become quite twisted and sometimes misused and actually leave us with less answers
and less clarity in understanding them before. And the stakes are also really high, right? When it comes to love, everything takes on a whole new level of significance. Because love is such a soft and vulnerable part of us. And at the end of the day, it's kind of all that we want to be seen and cared for and adored and spoiled. We probably also know what it feels like to be hurt and disappointed, how hard it is to find a real connection amongst dozens of dead ends and duds. So when somebody comes along and seemingly offers us everything that we've ever wanted
and has no faults, we can fall pretty quickly. The hard part is discerning when that connection and all those brilliant acts of service and gifts and affirmations is derived from an organic place or when it is potentially a facade, a sign of something more sinister. that is to come, or maybe even a habit that this person has learned to kind of entice you in and then switch everything around when they have you. So let's talk about it today. What is the actual psychology behind love bombing? Where does this concept come from? What does it have in common with cults and Snapchat? What are some of the biggest signs and, of course, the distinction
between once again something real and something artificial. Love versus love bombing. And how can we actually tell? I also want to talk about what makes some of us more susceptible to these behaviours and why it is definitely not your fault that you and me and everyone seems to get very caught up in this whirlwind of romance. But also some of the questions to really help you discern and determine what's actually going on. Whether you can really trust this situation, you can really trust this person's
actions or whether it's time to maybe get out. So all of that and more. We have so much to talk about. The psychology behind this is fascinating, at times overwhelming. Without further ado, let's get into it. We all have some concept of what it means to be love bombed. Flowers every day. I love yous after the first date, promises of marriage by date three. You know, huge extravagant gifts, meeting the family, wanting to spend every second with you, very much being swept off your feet with grand gestures, ego boosts, and like a high level of commitment from the beginning that you may have always wanted from somebody. The way I like to put it is that a relationship that contains love bombing
appears to be like a typical relationship timeline on steroids. And you know what? it probably feels incredibly nice. That is the whole purpose of love bombing, you know, is it's to induce feelings of closeness and passion and intimacy and affection as soon as possible. And it's only natural that when this happens, you know, all of those logical and rational centres of our brains are essentially overridden by the very powerful chemical reactions that are happening in the other parts of our brain.
that are responsible for processing emotion. These areas are being flooded with dopamine and serotonin in response to this other person's affection and admiration. It is a very biological process at its core when we really examine it deep down. We respond so positively to displays of love. We crave so deeply intimacy and affection that when it is given to us, it's like fireworks. It's like everything in our brain goes into over time. drive. But under that pleasant, sometimes even addictive feeling is often a sinister intention.
Love bombing is at the end of the day an attempt to influence a person through demonstrations of attention and affection that will lower our defences and our ability to detect red flags, but also attach and bond us very quickly to that person who is displaying these behaviors. There is a benefit for them that we are perhaps not seeing. We are blinded by their extreme kindness and love. And that benefit may be to soothe their own insecurities and abandonment issues. It may be to create a power dynamic that means we will never leave them and they'll have all the control. It may be to create dependence, to control and manipulate, or to just, they get the exciting feelings from those early days. That's what they really want. And then when they're bored,
they leave. The sinister or ulterior intentions, motivations of love. love bumming, that is a core characteristic of this behavior. You cannot have love bumming without that second component. And we can see that by really diving into the history of where the term has come from. So this behavior first got its name from a series of cults, including the Unification Church of the United States and the People's Temple, which you might know as the cult responsible for the Jonestown Massacre, and also another famous cult called the Branch Davidians, which was responsible for the Waco siege. So, you know, a very dark history. And the reason that this term was created was because these cults quickly discovered that excessive positive
reinforcement, excessive displays of friendship and kinship, gifts and incentives, they were a really great way to get new members and to prevent them from leaving. This was one of their tactics for winning people over and building trust but also dependency and allegiance on a very short timeline. And as awful as it was, for their purpose it was very smart. They took one of our core needs, love and belonging, which sits only above our biological needs for food and water and our safety needs for security, and they artificially manipulated it to achieve what they wanted, which was total psychological control. If it could be used in those circumstances, and it definitely is, it can also be used in everyday and one-on-one relationships like in dating or even in friendship.
It's not like they were the first people to discover this, but they were the first to really use it for very extreme, large, sinister campaigns to win people over. Here is the thing that a lot of us don't realize though, but what we typically see as love bombing, the extravagance, the excitement, that is really only the first stage. So according to the psychiatrist Dale Archer, who did a lot of his initial research in his career on love bombing, he talked to patients, he heard about their experiences, love bombing actually tends to occur in three phases. So the idealization phase comes first. That is what we typically see is love bombing. Your partner really bombards you with excessive affection to draw you in,
to let your guard down. You know, I've already mentioned a few signs of this, but some others that therapists often speak of include, you know, your partner rushes into locking things down. They're really jealous of your family and friends. They show up even when they weren't invited. They like you better when you're alone. They overcommuting. their love to the point where it may even make you feel uncomfortable. And at first it may seem too good to be true or too easy. And that is the purpose. That is what we want. That is what they want because what comes after that is the devaluation phase. And this is where we can really categorize their behavior
as love bumming. When it feels like the honeymoon period kind of suddenly bursts overnight. Once you start to let your guard down and get comfortable in this relationship, the red flags start to peer because they've won your trust. They may try to exert control over you in a variety of ways, being very demanding of your time, being very upset when you make plans without them, they might limit your access to your friends and family, they may start fights just to kind of exert control over you and to stop you from going to events. You know, a lot of emotional manipulation, a lot of gaslighting. The gifts, you know, they become less regular. The compliments are also mixed in with insults, but we keep thinking back to those early days and expecting this past version of them
and this past version of our love to come back because of how deeply rewired the idealization phase has made us. In really severe cases, we don't just see psychological manipulation and emotional abuse, but also physical abuse. And when you confront them, what you enter in that moment is the third stage. And the third stage is the discard phase. When you try and work things through with them, when you instigate meaningful conversation, when you attempt to reset healthy boundaries, this person your partner may avoid accountability by refusing to cooperate, refusing to talk about it, refusing to compromise, or by abandoning the relationship altogether. And this can leave you feeling really confused and really disorientated because, you know, a couple weeks ago, it was like
the most brilliant, beautiful TV romance of the century, and now here you are, alone. There's also, you know, likely to be some level of dependence and emotional reliance, which means that we've been so, like, hyped up by these huge feelings and emotions that we can't help but kind of feel compelled to go back and to try and win them over and to try and see what went wrong and we really want the relationship to work. And that is when the love bumming cycle typically begins again. This person attempts to repair the bond or repair the wound that they have left by doing what they know works, which is all of those extreme examples of love. This is important to note because, you know, this might sound controversial,
but the behaviours we typically associate with love bombing, those things that we see in the first stage, are, in themselves and alone, they're not evil or manipulative. Actually, they're pretty special, you know, it's not all that impossible that someone may actually fall head over heels with you, and it could be like a natural and an intense reaction. It's not like you cannot accept flowers because it's love bobbing. Somebody might say, I love you a little bit too,
soon, you know, because they're, it's just human. Some people just really do get in their feelings and have no intention of manipulating you. But it's what comes after that. It's phase two and phase three that really create the love bombing cycle and situation. As I've already mentioned, you know, love bombing can become also a part of a cycle of abuse whereby it's not just that they use these, you know, activities and behaviors to entice you, but they use them to control you and they use them as a way of reconciling with you after arguments, after incidences of abuse. So there was this really amazing article about this by a women's aid group, which I'll put in the description. And in that article, this is what they had to say. Love bombing becomes
an effective tool to abusers as they exert coercive control over a partner because it is intended to keep you still hopeful even when it all goes bad and it's that hope that, you know, causes people to sometimes stay. So let's move on. Let's talk about why it is that people love bomb. What's going on in their brains? What's the need here? There is a concept here that we haven't spoken about yet that really needs to be brought up when we're having conversations about lovebombing. You cannot talk about love bombing without also talking about narcissism. Narcissism for a quick catch-up describes basically a network of personality traits that centre around an extreme sense of self-involvement and self-importance.
A person displaying narcissistic traits or who has narcissistic personality disorder is preoccupied by their own interests and needs, even if they are at the expense of somebody else. The only thing they want from you is what you can give them. They want your attention, they want your admiration, they want, everything is for them. That's basically what narcissism is. The person is only focused on what they seek to gain from a situation.
So I don't think that it will come as a surprise that there is a significant correlation between narcissism, personality traits and love bombing. In a really fascinating study published in 2017, researchers observed almost 500 college students, their personalities, their relationship formation, and they found that love bombing was used as a way to form relationships, especially and specifically amongst individuals who reported A, low self-esteem, B, an insecure attachment, and C, narcissistic personality traits. This makes a lot of sense because, as one researcher put it, the psychological reasoning behind
love bombing is, I need to get you to trust me. I need you to only want me and not somebody else. I want to get on your good side. I want to build your trust so that when I discard you later, you're not going to know what's coming and I will never be the one who feels abandoned or rejected. I always get to be the one who was in control because that way I am the one who always gets my needs met. By overwhelming somebody with positive reinforcement, the love bummer creates a sense of dependency and the recipient may feel that they could never find such an intense affection
and validation anywhere else. So it makes it very hard, makes it very difficult for you to want to leave, even when the relationship turns sour. Love bombing is manipulation for personal gain, but it's also a way to protect their ego. They get to have you and your affection as quickly and when they want it. They get to play the game. They get to keep you invested. And then when they're done, they get to end it when they want.
The root of love bombing is manipulation, but it's also control and power. It's not just narcissism that drives this, you know, disorganize. and insecure attachment also plays a role. So the authors of that, same paper I just referenced, also mentioned it briefly, but people with an anxious attachment style may find themselves engaging in some
of the behaviours that look like love bombing and not always for the purposes of control, but because of an innate insecurity and fear that causes them to speed up the relationship out of a worry that the other person will leave if they are given the chance. If they
apply, all of these tactics for bonding somebody to them, if they shower them in praise and gifts and feelings, there is less chance of rejection or heartbreak. It is still manipulative. It is intended to influence the situation, but for very different reasons. Does it make it healthier? Absolutely not. Because it does still involve creating a false environment and artificial circumstances that make them seem like the perfect match until they start to feel better about the situation, until they start to feel secure, until they have you. So it is just another explanation for why somebody might instigate this pattern of behaviours. A final explanation, you know, there are quite a few more, but these are the big
three. The final explanation I want to mention for why people love bomb has to do with what we might call intensity addiction. There are some people out there who just love the honeymoon phase. That's all they're here for. And so they have a brief window to squeeze in all the deep emotions. the love, the ecstasy, the beauty of falling in love, before things start to get too serious and then they can evacuate. Fast tracking a relationship through love bombing gives them the intense high that they want without the commitment. It is a great way to get all the highs without never having to experience the lows
because they leave after only a few months before the honeymoon phase is over and the whole time they've had a lot of the power. I will give these individuals some level of grace. Often they have no idea that this is what they're doing. It is a subconscious relationship pattern that has been ingrained in them for a long time, maybe because they were once hurt, maybe because they just are too scared of commitment. And often the feelings are somewhat real.
And if you ask them for a relationship timeline, they do care about the people they dated. But there are these almost gap. in their memories around why the relationship ended, because acknowledging that perhaps it was most likely them would mean that they would have to recognize that their acceleration of the timeline was actually what caused it to crash and burn.
And it's often us that are the casualties, because they've already clocked out. They've already checked out of the relationship as soon as it wasn't fun anymore. I think from this we can kind of determine a little bit of a love-bombing spectrum or scale. At one end, we have narcissism and individuals who are deliberate and planned about their desire to have us to control us, to manipulate. And then we have people at the other end
whose relationship habits and patterns are just completely chaotic and careless. But the thing is, we are still the ones who get hurt in the process. And here's the thing. Even if their intentions aren't malicious, even when it feels good, we really, we want. want a love that lasts. That's what we want. We want a healthy, sustaining love, not one of instant gratification, not a temporary or artificial feeling that is built on the basis of exhilaration and fast-paced emotions. That will eventually fade. And it's hard to tell sometimes. Let me tell you that. It's especially hard to tell when you have maybe spent a good deal of time dealing with people who give you absolutely nothing, or the bare minimum. You know, sometimes it is it, it's a
refreshing for somebody to come and come along and whine and dine us. And you do deserve that. You deserve great deep love. It's just about distinguishing between when that is a real sign of love, when that is a real connection versus love bombing. So that is what we're going to talk about. Next, what is the distinction? How can we tell and how can we protect ourselves after this short break? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is a number of people who take the stairs when there also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends,
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Love is meant to feel amazing, and you are meant to be spoiled and treated well. you really do deserve someone who wants to make your life better and thinks that you are amazing and gives you little gifts showing you that they're thinking of you and sees a future with you. But the healthy version of this comes with time. It's something that I've definitely realized the older I've gotten, the more relationships I've been in, the more relationships I've seen my friends be in and I've observed.
Those that are built slowly are built on real feeling. those that emerge overnight or often built on impulse or something artificial and short-lived. There are a few key relationship characteristics that I think distinguish or differ between love-bumbing and love. These are typically pacing. Love-bumbing involves an intense and rapid escalation of the relationship. The love-bumber will push very quickly for commitment and intense closeness very early on. You know, love, on the other hand, and takes time because closeness comes from experience and shared memories and values and growth
as a partnership. The other component is inconsistency. Love should be consistent. Yes, you know, sometimes there are bumps in the road, but you know that the road is always going to be there and you know that the road will continue on. With love bumming, you might not know. Underneath the bright, brilliant feelings is often a twinge of anxiety and worry. Most people call that intuition, but we can confuse it with passion. Anxiety and excitement are very similar on a physical level. In both situations, our heart beats faster, our cortisol surges, our body is prepared for action, everything feels a bit tingly.
It's how we interpret that emotion, our cognitions and our perceptions that determine what we see it as. It is very easy to ignore our gut feeling about a situation when it just feels. feels so sweet and good. But I think as the saying goes, if it feels too good to be true, maybe it is, and maybe it is valuable to interrogate the origin of that feeling. Another distinction, idealization and promises. Someone who has good intentions won't over-promise. They won't make commitments they can't keep, not just because they don't want to disappoint you, but also because they also want to be sure themselves. They don't want to get caught up.
that's really mature, and it shows respect and a natural level of caution. On the other hand, love bombers are not going to hold back. Marriage, next month, let's do it. Should we move in together? Yes, absolutely. Are you the love of my life? Yes, no doubts about it. We've only known each other for a week.
I still know. You get the picture. It's incredibly grandiose. And another factor in which these kind of relationship types, I don't know whether to call that, in which love and love bombing differ is, is power, is power, isolation, and control. It is my belief that healthy love isn't just sustained by what happens between you two, but also what you are allowed to pursue beyond the relationship.
It's sustained by the things that exist outside of your kind of union. You have your own friends, you have your own interests in lives, but with love bombing, the relationship is all consuming. It is the center of your universe. If this is sounding very similar to codependency, that is because it is. There is this very similar concept when we talk about codependency called affection flooding. And I heard about this from a podcast called Relationships Made Easy, and the host talks about how affection flooding occurs when a codependent person
is engulfing their partner with an avalanche of affection and attention, driven by their deep-seated need for validation and external affirmation. It is very similar to love bombing, and the outcome in both situations is that you do become almost conjoined or attached to your partner. Everything becomes, you know, just them. All thoughts lead back to them. All actions or behaviour or choices lead back to them. I want to quickly stipulate.
I don't blame anybody who has ever been love-bombed and stayed, because it would be so hard to turn down, especially, as I said before, if you've gone through a number of situations or relationships in which all you ever wanted what, you know, was exactly what this person is now giving you. Commitment, excitement, generosity, love. It's even harder when our sense of self or our self-esteem has already been diminished by a previous situation that has just made us feel really understanding. undeserving or unlovable. This person, you know, when they come along and they have all these
grand gestures, they can seem like our white night. But here are a series of very important questions to help you discern whether that is love or love bumming. How does the pace of the relationship make you feel? And where do you feel these feelings? In your stomach, in your heart, in your body. is there a difference between what you're feeling and a similar feeling of anxiety? Are you feeling stable and sure and confident or excited and bubbly and perhaps anxious? If you went away for a month and came back, would the relationship change? Would you be worried about the passion fading? What do you have in common?
Do you have shared interests? Do you have shared values? is there a genuine foundation to your relationship? Does it feel like there won't be a future if the future doesn't happen now? If you slowed everything down, would they still be there? And finally, is your life still yours or is your life your relationship? Is your relationship and your attachment to this person taking over? These questions are important because they give us a chance to,
pause and really assess, you know, what we are experiencing based on what we have established are the distinctions between love and love bombing. It kind of gives us a bit of a brief time out to switch on that critical thinking and logical part of our brain and just explore whether this is all too good to be true or made to last. If it all keeps coming back to that one explanation only, this is love bombing, there are a few things that we can do. First thing, I get wanting to just like wait it out and see if things change because it's really hard to not want to bathe in that glow of feeling really wanted and feeling really loved. But I want you to remember the more time you stay is time that you will continue to feel
connected to this person. The feel good feelings are kind of the poison. They are the weapon in the situation. They are a manipulation strategy. And it's the thing that will keep you attached. even if you think that you can keep some emotional distance, sometimes we just don't have as much control as we think. And so the best thing to do is to kind of,
firstly, pull back and check their reaction and practice setting some boundaries. You know, just say to them, I'm sorry I can't see you this weekend. Please don't send me gifts at work. Please don't show up and announced. Set a boundary and see how they respond. if they get incredibly aggressive or defensive or upset,
I think that's a pretty clear sign that what's happening right here is something that is going to eventually turn into something much worse. If you find that this person is not responsive or respectful of your boundaries, get out. Get out of that situation. Remember those three phases that we spoke about before? Yeah, I think the second and the third stage is really where once they have their claws in you, they know. They know what they have. And it becomes really hard for you to leave. Psychologically, emotionally, socially, physically, it becomes so much harder because they do have the control.
So I do just really want to remind you, firstly, it's not your fault if that is something that you are going through right now. It is only natural that you felt really compelled and attracted to this person. But please don't confuse chemistry with compatibility. Chemistry will have you feeling amazing, but it's short-lived. Compatibility is a slow burn. It is an alignment. It is a bond that grows over time. It has shared values.
It has shared experiences. And it's real. And love bombing is artificial. So just a reminder that what feels good now is not going to feel as amazing in three months or six months. And you could have had that time to really resettle into yourself and find somebody who, yeah, we'll do all the really nice things that will also be committed to staying and staying because they love you and care about you, not because they want to control you. So I hope that you have at least learned something from this episode.
you've taken something away. Thank you for listening. Thank you for coming along for the journey. If there is somebody in your life who you think might benefit from hearing this episode, please feel free to share it with them. It also allows us to reach new ears, reach new people. Make sure that you are following along.
And if you want to, it only takes a couple of seconds to leave us five stars. It really makes my day. If you want to leave a review as well, I read them all and they are quite special to me. So thank you so much for, yeah, considering it. I would love to hear from you as well. If you have anything else you want to contribute to this episode,
if you have an episode suggestion, we are always open to hearing feedback to hearing ideas, topics that you want us to explore. So make sure that you are following me at that psychology podcast or you want to see behind the scenes. You can follow me at Gemma Spagg. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. and we will talk soon.
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.